[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abend eine bittere medizin nennt
bundeswirtschaftsminister habeck die gas
umlage die ab oktober greifen und
verhindern soll dass der deutsche
energiemarkt zusammenbricht bitter in
der tat für alle gaskunden
denn es wird teurer seit heute steht
fest um
2,4 cent pro kilowattstunde das liegt
unter den schlimmsten szenarien
die in den letzten wochen gehandelt
wurden bedeutet aber für viele eine
immense mehrbelastung frank buchwald aus
berlin
die nachricht kam um kurz vor zwölf ein
trading europe bisher nur insidern
bekannt teilt mitunter was gibt's neues
die gas umlage wird bei 2,4 19 cent
liegen pro kilowattstunde ab erster
oktober nicht ganz so hoch wie
befürchtet trotzdem keine gute nachricht
für millionen gaskunden der minister
aber so sagt er hat keine andere wahl
die alternative ist nicht keine umlage
die alternative wäre der zusammenbruch
des deutschen energiemarktes gewesen und
damit weite teile des europäischen
energiemarktes der kanzler heute zu
besuch in oslo scholz gibt sich
erleichtert weil es nun doch nicht fünf
cent geworden sind und bekräftigt er
werde die menschen nicht allein lassen
wir wissen wie eng die rücklagen sind
dass manche bürgerinnen und bürger gar
keine haben dass viele das geld das sie
im monat verdienen auch wieder ausgeben
und selbst diejenigen die ein bisschen
mehr haben haben es deshalb noch lange
nicht dicke und deshalb ist es wichtig
dass wir eine solche zusätzliche
entlastung über die beiden großen pakete
von 30 milliarden hinaus die wir bereits
gemacht haben auf den weg bringen wie
das jedoch genau aussehen soll bleibt
bisher unklar in der koalition
finanzminister linden hat anfang august
ein inflationsausgleichs gesetz
vorgelegt das vor allem mittlere
einkommen entlasten soll
wir sollten jetzt schnell rangehen und
auch innerhalb der koalition auf den
inflationsausgleich einigen es ein gutes
instrument ist auch eine frage der
fairness gegenüber der hart arbeitende
mitte der gesellschaft und ich denke
kleine und mittlere einkommen sollten
gerade wegen der gestiegenen
energiepreise jetzt entlassung erfahren
deswegen der inflationsausgleich linke
grüne und teile der spd kritisieren dass
pläne jedoch als unsozial die ampel
streitet und verliert wertvolle zeit
meinen verbraucherschützer und
opposition beim belasten ist diese
koalition sich sehr schnell einig nur
beim entlasten warten wir seit wochen es
wird jeden tag gestritten es gibt jeden
tag einen neuen vorschlag kleinere und
mittlere einkommen brauchen diese
entlastung aber dringend die leiden
jeden tag unter den hohen preisen zu
lange die regierung streitet über
weitere entlastungsmaßnahmen muss auch
die umlage ausgesetzt werden erst das
hilfspaket steht darf auch die umlage
kommen es war füllen sich deutschlands
große gasspeicher schneller auch als
erwartet viele menschen aber fragen sich
ob sie sich das gas im nächsten winter
überhaupt noch leisten können und die
umlage kommt ja nun noch obendrauf
2,41 19 das also ist die zahl des tages
und was das konkret bedeutet rechnet
sich heute abend vielleicht gerade
mancher oder manche aus offen ist ob die
mehrwertsteuer noch oben drauf kommt das
will der bundesfinanzminister
zweites gestern im zdf sommerinterview
angekündigt vermeiden über die folgen
der gasanlage für verbraucher und
gesellschaft reden wir gleich mit
bundeswirtschaftsminister habeck nach
einem fakten überblick von felix
johannes
für einen vierköpfigen haushalt mit
20.000 kilowattstunden jahresverbrauch
bedeutet die gasanlage mehrkosten von
rund 484 euro im jahr ohne
mehrwertsteuer käme diese noch oben
drauf wären es 576 euro pro jahr ein
zwei personen haushalt könnte demnach
bei rund
288 euro liegen ein ein personen
haushalt bei mehrkosten von rund 144
euro im jahr inklusive mehrwertsteuer
tragen müssen kunden zudem die regulären
preiserhöhungen zum vergleich vor einem
jahr lagen die kosten pro kilowattstunde
erdgas noch bei unter sechs cent
inzwischen müssen neukunden etwa 28 cent
pro kilowattstunde zahlen die umlage
soll erdgas importeuren wie juniper
ermöglichen ihre zusatzkosten durch die
folgen des kriegs in der ukraine weiter
zu geben und gleichmäßig zu verteilen
russland hatte seine gaslieferungen nach
deutschland gedrosselt und
energiekonzerne gezwungen auf dem
weltmarkt teure alternativen einzukaufen
mit der umlage sollen insolvenzen
verhindert werden für voraussichtlich
zwei heizperioden bis april
2024 tritt der mechanismus in kraft alle
drei monate kann die höhe der umlage
angepasst werden unklar ist ob kunden
mit festpreis verträgen überhaupt zur
kasse gebeten werden dürfen und auch ob
das erheben der mehrwertsteuer auf die
gasanlage wegfallen kann darum hatte
finanzminister linda die eu kommission
in brüssel gebeten
also noch einige offene fragen aber
beantwortet ist diese es wird für die
kunden
privathaushalte wie unternehmen teurer
der bundeswirtschaftsminister ist uns
aus berlin zugeschaltet jungen am
theater weggeschossen guten haben 2,4
cent sie haben die umlage heute
verteidigt als die gerechteste mögliche
form um die gasimporteure zu stützen und
damit den energiemarkt heißt aber dann
im umkehrschluss auch herr habeck die
umlage wird in jedem fall
ungerechtigkeiten produzieren unwuchten
würde ich sagen es ist natürlich so dass
es für politiker nicht attraktiv ist
höhere belastungen zu verkünden es ist
ein schritt der zumutung bereithält für
deutschland umgekehrt hätten wir keine
lösung für ein geschäftsmodell also
einnahmemöglichkeiten für die
unternehmen gefunden die russische gas
ausfälle jetzt kompensieren müssen mit
der deutsche energiemarkt in die knie
gegangen und dann hätten sehr viele
bürgerinnen und bürger jetzt sich einen
neuen verbraucher suchen müssen oder gar
kein meer gefunden für weitaus höhere
preise deswegen ist das ein harter
schritt aber eine der notwendig ist wie
so viele entscheidungen in diesen tagen
und sie sagen auch es gab im grunde
jetzt keine bessere idee die höhe der
umlage basiert ja auf angaben die die
gasunternehmen
selbst gemacht haben darüber wie hoch
jetzt ihre zusatzkosten für den gas
ersatz sind das wurde dann wenn ich es
richtig verstanden habe auf
plausibilität geprüft ist ihnen bei
diesem vorgehen eigentlich wohl bestimmt
da nicht im grunde die gaswirtschaft
selbst wie viel sie dann bekommen soll
nein ganz im gegenteil es ist ja ein
voraus gezogener schritt der damit man
die belastungen jetzt vermisst mehrfach
geprüft wurde erst von
wirtschaftsprüfern dann ob das verfahren
richtig ist von der bundesnetzagentur
und es ist ein schritt der auf einer
prognose beruht das heißt es wird noch
spitz abgerechnet die unternehmen haben
gegenüber den verschiedenen
institutionen dargelegt wie hoch ihre
mehr beschaffungskosten von russischen
gas sind und das gilt dann ab oktober
sollten die preise steigen kann sein
dass die umlage noch höher wird sollten
sie fallen gegenüber den prognosen nicht
den biss zeitraum jetzt dass sie auch
niedriger wird also da ist das ist ein
fehler kommt nachvollziehbarer und am
ende auch sehr transparent
auszubildender schritt und sie sagen
aber auch es kann sogar noch mehr werden
jetzt gab es aber auch die rwe und
shader abgewunken haben wir brauchten
die umlage nicht deshalb noch mal die
frage war es wirklich alternativlos
gemessen an den rahmenbedingungen unter
denen wir politik machen das heißt dass
der haushalt nicht zur kompensation zur
verfügung steht wegen der
haushaltspolitischen bedingungen die wir
haben war es trotzdem nicht
alternativlos wenn sie mich so fragen
denn man hätte auch ist so machen könnte
es ist ja eine umlage die jetzt alle
menschen die gas verbrauchen
ein stück weit tragen das heißt wir
verbreitern die last der schultern man
hätte sich auch so entscheiden können
dass nur diejenigen bürgerinnen und
bürgern mit diejenigen unternehmen die
spezifisch bei einem unternehmen ein
ausfall erstattet müssen dass die zur
kasse gebeten werden dann wäre ungefähr
die hälfte von deutschland doppelt so
hoch vielleicht höher belastet worden
und die andere hälfte gar nicht das wäre
sozialpolitisch und demokratisch noch
schwieriger gewesen deswegen
alternativlos ist so wenig in der
politik das ist auch kein begriff den
ich gerne mag aber es ist die bessere
alternative die wir heute gewählt haben
wenngleich sie hohe belastungen mit sich
bringt offen ist noch was mit der
mehrwertsteuer ist bei dem wunsch dass
die mehrwertsteuer entfallen soll da
sind sie sicher mit dem
bundesfinanzminister christa lindner
einig ansonsten aber mit ihm bei wenig
oder fast nichts hat man den eindruck
eine über gewinn steuer die wollen sie
nicht wie wollen sie eher nicht sie
halten sein kampf gegen die kalte
progression
obwohl es ja auch eine entlastung ist
für nachrangig für die bürger wäre nicht
so schlecht man wüsste was nun kommt ja
aber wir sind verschiedene parteien fdp
grüne spd in einer koalition wäre sie
sich anschauen was wir in dem letzten
halben jahr unter extremsten bedingungen
doch an großen entscheidungen getroffen
haben so haben wir das doch vernünftig
hinbekommen und das ist eine debatte
gibt das ist auszuhalten in einer
demokratie und wir werden auch weiter zu
guten starken lösungen kommen in
deutschland sicher durch diese krise
durch schön also privatkunden werden
belastet werden sie versprechen weitere
entlastungen der bundeskanzler auch der
mittelstand warnt jetzt auch schon vor
einer pleitewelle von kleinen
mittelständischen betrieben bäckereien
zum beispiel die einen erheblichen
energiebedarf haben was können die von
bundeswirtschaftsminister erwarten das
muss man jetzt einmal trennen die umlage
und die allgemeinen höheren
energiekosten die ja nicht nur im
gasbereich anfallen sondern auch
beispielsweise im strombereich und die
sind in der tat für die allermeisten
unternehmen eine gigantische
herausforderung um nicht zu sagen ein
problem die umlage sei jetzt nach einer
für einige menschen und viele
verbrauchern verbraucher ist es auch
eine belastung für andere nicht in dem
maße 24 cent bei einem kann man ja
rechnen bei einem verbrauch der dann
durchschnitt ist einige werden das
wegducken wegducken können wegdrücken
können andere weniger was die
unternehmen angeht so haben wir ein
system aufgebaut das wirtschafts hilfen
gewährt das ist auch unter den
haushalterischen bedingungen eng
gestrickt das sind im wolle die
unternehmen die in einem internationalen
wettbewerb stehen und ihre preise nicht
an die verbraucher und die verbraucher
weitergeben können und ob es da noch
nach steuerungs bedarf gibt das schauen
wir uns gerade noch einmal sehr genau an
also das system arbeitet so die preise
wollen wir nicht subventionieren weil
dadurch dann das preissignale markt viel
wir müssen die energie sparen aber
gezielte unterstützung für die
verbraucher und die verbraucher wie für
die unternehmen die muss kommen sie soll
auch zeitgleich kommen mit den
preiserhöhungen die jetzt auf
deutschland zu holen dann spricht der
bundeswirtschaftsminister vielen dank
nach berliner herr beck dagegen
das gespräch haben wir am abend
aufgezeichnet ein umfangreiches paket
zum thema gas umlage mit
beispielrechnungen für verschiedene
wohnungsgrößen zum beispiel finden sie
bei zdf heute sehr lohnenswert und nun
zunächst weitere nachrichten mit gundula
gause
russlands präsident putin hat fast sechs
monate nach beginn seines
angriffskrieges gegen die ukraine das
ziel einer kompletten einnahme des
donners bekräftigt dort im osten der
ukraine wird weiter schwer gekämpft nach
russischen angaben wurden dabei hunderte
ukrainische soldaten getötet unterdessen
ist der erste getreidefrachter im
auftrag der vereinten nationen mit
23.000 tonnen weizen auf dem weg nach
äthiopien
die un hoffen auf regelmäßige getreide
lieferungen für vom hunger bedrohten
regionen in afghanistan haben die
taliban anlässlich ihrer machtübernahme
heute vor einem jahr einen feiertag für
diesen 15 august ausgerufen die
international isolierten machthaber
ließen auf den straßen kabuls den sieg
über die usa fahren nach der
geschlossenen us botschaft skandierten
kämpfer lang lebe der islam verschwiegen
werden armut beschneidung von
frauenrechten und schwere
menschenrechtsverletzungen
ein gericht der militärjunta in myanmar
hat die entmachtete regierungschefin sun
tzu chi zu weiteren sechs jahren haft
verurteilt die
friedensnobelpreisträgerin wurde in vier
fällen der korruption für schuldig
befunden ihre gefängnisstrafe erhöht
sich damit auf 17 jahre die usa und die
eu forderten erneut die freilassung der
77-jährigen
indien hat den 75 jahrestag seiner
unabhängigkeit von großbritannien
gefeiert mit der auflösung der kolonien
entstanden 1947 das mehrheitlich
hinduistischen indien und das islamische
pakistan indiens premier modi rief dazu
auf den kolonialismus in den köpfen
loszuwerden er sehe indien in 25 jahren
als voll entwickelte wirtschaftsmacht
mit stolz auf ihr kulturelles erbe die
indische opposition kritisiert modi
nutzte das jubiläum zu 1 eine
glorifizierung
in kenia ist der bisherige vizepräsident
william ruto zum neuen staatschef
gewählt worden eine hauchdünne mehrheit
von 50,5 prozent für ruto bestätigte die
wahlkommission damit ist der langjährige
oppositionsführer odinga erneut
unterlegen seine anhänger wollen das
ergebnis nicht akzeptieren dass zudem
von vier der sieben mitglieder der
wahlkommission nicht anerkannt wird nach
der verkündung kam es zu tumulten und
protesten
es ist eine tragödie und wird nun
langsam zum skandal dass massive
fischsterben in der oder auch heute
wurden tonnen toter fische eingesammelt
eine erklärung für diese gravierende
umweltkatastrophe gibt es noch immer
nicht auch tage nach beginn des großen
sterbens eine deutsch-polnische task
force soll nun die ursachen forschung
vorantreiben aber zweifel am
aufklärungswillen der polnischen
behörden bleiben aus brandenburg nicola
albrecht in polen ist heute feiertag
doch die baggerfahrer an den zusperren
müssen arbeiten und schaufeln wieder
massenweise toten fisch aus der oder
umweltverbände schätzen dass insgesamt
bereits 100 tonnen fisch verendet sind
500 kilometer flusslauf seien betroffen
in brandenburg zählen sie vor allem auf
freiwillige helfer die seit tagen
nonstop stinkenden fischkadaver mit
ihren händen aus der oder ziehen allein
das team um fischerei meister henry
schneider schafft täglich rund 300
kilogramm und langsam kommen sie an ihre
grenzen
der landkreis hat uns darum gebeten sie
zu entsorgen
darüber natürlich rein kommt ja und
natürlich auch die vogelwelt ein
bisschen zu schützen aber wir schaffen
nicht alle ist die muscheln kommen hoch
die die schnecken kommen hoch wie die
für schreier gegen die adler gehen ran
hier wird alle sterben sie vergiften
sich mit das ist unser problem die
ursache für das massive fischsterben ist
nach wie vor nicht bekannt ein hoher
salzgehalt und ph-wert wurden
festgestellt eine quecksilbervergiftung
gilt als unwahrscheinlich
was bleibt ist der verdacht dass auf
polnischer seite illegal chemikalien in
die oder eingeleitet wurden der unmut
über fehlende informationen aus polen
immer noch groß bin froh über jeden
schafften wir ausschließen können aber
noch dringender ist es natürlich jetzt
zu wissen was ist genau passiert und da
brauchen wir dringend die zusammenarbeit
mit den polnischen behörden weil ich
glaube dass es da auch kenntnisse gibt
die wir heute noch nicht haben polen
verspricht nun die toten fische in
seinem zentrallabor auf 300 mögliche
stoffe zu untersuchen auch in
deutschland laufen die analysen und
proben noch doch die zeit drängt denn
die katastrophe beschränkt sich nicht
auf das fischsterben
wir haben aber natürlich probleme weil
ich auch haufenweise tote muscheln
gesehen habe dass andere arten die also
auch einen längeren zyklus haben um sich
wieder zu regenerieren
tatsächlich geschädigt sind deswegen
reden wir auch nicht nur vom
fischsterben sondern wir haben ein
ökosystem schaden dass das ökosystem der
oder schon jetzt nachhaltig geschädigt
ist eine regeneration jahre dauern
könnte vermuten auch umweltschützer wir
wissen dass es fatale schäden hat das
sehr viele tiere sehr viele organismen
in den fluss absterben und das dauert
natürlich schon dann einige jahre bis
wir da wieder auf einem ähnlichen stand
sind wie wir das vor der katastrophe
waren in polen wird es morgen eine
regierungs debatte über die ursachen und
den vermutlich kriminellen hintergrund
geben in deutschland hofft man auf
ergebnisse der laboruntersuchungen und
an der oder mündung bei stettin redmann
dringend vom baden ab denn auch dort
könnte sich die oder giftwelle noch
intensivieren
der rundfunkrat des rbb hat seine
zurückgetretene intendantin am abend von
ihrem amt abberufen mit sofortiger
wirkung patricia schlesinger ist damit
befeuert sie hat sich noch einmal
erklärt und entschuldigt helfen konnte
das nicht mehr die berliner
generalstaatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt aufgeklärt ist der skandal der
den gesamten öffentlich-rechtlichen
rundfunk in misskredit bringt längst
nicht doch der rundfunkrat sah
ausreichende gründe für seine
entscheidung das ist auch ein
befreiungsschlag denn die
aufsichtsgremien und deren mangelnde
kontrolle rücken jetzt in den fokus auch
in der rbb christa knöpfle berichtet
vor den türen des altehrwürdigen hauses
des rundfunks demonstrieren rbb
mitarbeiter protest gegen die eigene
chefin sie fordern stoppt im filz weg
mit den boni und bloß nicht weiter so
das ist die stimmung vor der
rundfunkratssitzung
wir wollen dass alles auf den tisch
kommt wir wollen 100 prozentige
aufklärung da darf auch nicht der hauch
eines zweifels bleiben dass irgendwas
nicht aufgeklärt wird und dafür steht
die belegschaft und so müssen wir uns
auf das konzentrieren was unsere aufgabe
ist gutes programm für die
gebührenzahler zu machen doch seit
wochen macht der rundfunk
berlin-brandenburg
negativschlagzeilen das problem heißt
patricia schlesinger als noch
intendantin nimmt sie überraschend an
der sitzung teil sie entschuldigt sich
es tue ihr unendlich leid professionell
wie menschlich so wörtlich der 61
jährigen journalistin werden
vetternwirtschaft und verschwendung
vorgeworfen dass springer portal
business insider hatte mit seinen
recherchen die affäre ausgelöst der
fokus der recherche lag vor allen dingen
darauf dieses netzwerk aufzudecken
zwischen patricia schlesinger ihrem
ehemann gerhard spörl und dem
verwaltungsrat chef daher auch
gleichzeitig der aufsichtsratschef der
messe ist wolf dieter wolf und das ist
ja dieses besondere dreiecksverhältnis
was daher über jahre existiert hat und
ausgerechnet gegen diese drei personen
ermittelt jetzt auch die
staatsanwaltschaft die aufdeckung
fragwürdiger beraterverträge für ein
geplantes digitales medienzentrum
brachte den stein ins rollen auch
schließt ihn als mann gerd spoerr soll
davon profitiert haben doch die liste
der vorwürfe ist länger ein teurer umbau
der chefetage für 1,4 millionen euro
während im kulturprogramm eine million
gestrichen wurde ein teurer dienstwagen
private essen auf rbb kosten und
umstrittenen boni zahlungen für die
geschäftsleitung seit einer woche
recherchiert ein fünfköpfiges rbb team
die frage wie war das möglich nun
intendant ist ja ein mensch mit einer
ganz ganz hohen machtfülle so viel macht
in einer hand hätte ich selber gar nicht
für möglich gehalten und da hilft am
ende nur 1 kontrolle kontrolle kontrolle
und die hat es offensichtlich nicht
gegeben über drei stunden tagte
rundfunkrat am ende ein klares votum mit
22 von 23 stimmen wird patricia
schlesinger abrufen mit sofortiger
wirkung und ohne abfindung die
abberufung ist durch krümmel person von
der frau stedinger bedingt die eine
außerordentliche kündigung des
dienstvertrages durch den rbb
rechtfertigen was heißt das für den
rundfunkrat auf dem hintergrund der
erfahrungen die wir gemacht haben können
wir nicht so weitermachen wie wir es
bisher immer gemacht haben wir werden
daraus lernen aus dem prozess das ende
einer dienstzeit
und während der rundfunkrat weiter tag
verlässt patricia schlesinger den rbb
nach sechs jahren amtszeit durch die
hintertür
in den nachrichten schauen wir jetzt auf
die aktuelle dürre und die folgen ja da
sind zusätzliche risiken für die
energieversorgung zu bedenken eben auch
aufgrund des niedrigen wasserstandes der
großen deutschen flüsse am rhein wurde
heute der niedrigste stand seit jahren
gemessen nur noch gut 30 cm bei stefanie
berit viele autofähren haben schon den
betrieb eingestellt wie steht es um die
binnenschifffahrt ja die binnenschiffer
kämpft weiterhin mit sinkenden
wasserpegel und frachtschiffe die in dem
gefährlich niedrigen wasser überhaupt
noch fahren können werden allmählich
knapp schon jetzt muss die fracht auf
mehrere schiffe verteilt werden damit
diese nicht aufgrund fahren die größte
herausforderung derzeit benzin heizöl
und diesel zur rechten zeit und in
ausreichender menge ihre zielorte zu
bringen denn für die
treibstoffversorgung ist der rhein die
wichtigste verkehrsader vor allem
süddeutschland ist bei seiner
energieversorgung von transporten auf
dem fluss angewiesen autofahrer in
süddeutschland bekommen bereits seit
wochen beim tanken die folgen des
niedrigwassers zu spüren und müssen für
gestiegene frachtkosten tiefer in die
tasche greifen und weil autofähren wegen
niedrigwasser den betrieb eingestellt
haben müssen pendler inzwischen riesen
umwege in kauf nehmen seit heute fallen
zusätzlich etliche reihen fairen
vorläufig aus für die versorgung mit
treibstoffen und kohle ist deutschlands
verkehrsreichste strom noch
alternativlos sind ausreichender menge
lassen sich derartige mengen an
energieträgern nicht einfach per bahn
und lastwagen transportieren und
abgesehen davon sind auch hier lkw und
fahrer derzeit knapp vielen daten
stephanie für diese informationen nach
frankfurt
in köln verschärft sich die kritik an
erzbischof woelki mehr als 60 pfarrer
gemeindereferentinnen und andere
funktionsträger des erzbistums
distanzieren sich in einer erklärung von
woelki und fordern einen neuanfang mit
personellen und systemischen
veränderungen anlass ist ein bericht des
kölner stadt-anzeigers über
kommunikationsstrategien zu denen
pr-experten dem kardinal im
missbrauchsskandal geraten haben sollen
betroffene fühlen sich
instrumentalisiert die katholische
basisbewegung maria 2.0 kritisiert mit
dieser aktion heute moralisches versagen
und
noch ein blick auf die schwimm wm in rom
da ist olympiasieger florian wellbrock
nach seiner corona bedingten pause
souverän ins finale über 1500 meter
freistil eingezogen und sein
zimmerkollege ohne braunschweig aus
berlin hat bronze über 50 meter rücken
geholt die vierte medaille für das
deutsche team sieben hundertstel
vorsprung reichten für platz drei ein
tränchen wie der 24 jährige sagt
es war ein toller leichtathletik abend
in münchen die european championships
werden vor ort langsam zum volksfest
olympia feeling in münchen und das
vermittelt sich auch beim zuschauen die
sportlichen highlights dieses tages aus
deutscher sicht hat silvia banken für
uns immer hintze hat es schon wieder
getan im sprint finale gewann die
cottbuserin ihre dritte goldmedaille bei
dieser em doch sie machte es spannend
gegen die starke französin mathilde hoch
fiel die entscheidung erst im dritten
lauf und noch dazu denkbar knapp im foto
finish gewann die sprinterin
zuvor hatte maximilian dörnbach bereits
das medaillenkonto der erfolgreichen
wahl radfahrer im 1000 meter zeitfahren
um eine bronzemedaille erhöht traumstart
für die deutschen leichtathleten am
ersten wettkampftag gab es im marathon
gleich zweimal gold mit einer
unglaublichen energieleistung war
richard ringer auf den letzten metern
noch zum europameister titel gestürmt
dem ersten für einen deutschen
marathonläufer zudem gewann das deutsche
männer-team gemeinsam silber die frauen
mannschaft lief dank sehr guter
einzelleistungen im zu team-gold dass
miriam becker als vierte die einzel
medaille knapp verpasste nur ein kleiner
wermutstropfen an einem erfolgreichen
tag
zehnkämpfer in die glaskugel liegt nach
dem ersten wettkampftag im soll und hat
gute chancen auf den titelgewinn der 24
jährige lief bestzeit über die 100 und
400 meter und lieferte auch im
weitsprung und kugelstoßen ordentliche
leistungen ab als siebter geht der
weltmeister von 2009 10 in den zweiten
tag an dem paul seine stärken ausspielen
kann in führung nach tag 1 der schweizer
simon hammer
also lohnt sich weiter zu schauen und
das war es an diesem montag von uns
beiden um 0.40 meldest durch kunden mit
unserem heute-journal update später
doppelschicht also jetzt erstmal bunter
kino
[Musik]
grün abends diese woche ringen uns
komplett neues wetter endlich gibt es
mal dies und die bringen auch regen mit
das spannendste tiefe dieses tief karin
sein dass uns mit kräftigen gewittern ab
der wochenmitte beschäftigen wird heute
nach gibt es auch noch einige gewitter
hier im nordosten deutschlands und auch
in ostbayern und dabei sinken die
temperaturen auf 19 grad an der
nordseeküste und bis 10 grad zum
beispiel im allgäu die temperaturen
morgen liegen zwischen 26 und 32 grad
dabei wird es hier in der lausitz oder
zum beispiel auch in der lüneburger
heide am heißesten in süddeutschland
gibt es morgen viel sonne im nordmeer
wolken da kann es auch mal für einen
kleinen regenschauer erreichen und an
der ostseeküste kann es auch mal blitzen
oder donnert es wäre jetzt wirklich mal
nötig dass es kräftig regnet und in den
gewittern können dann punktuell bis
samstag durchaus 60 bis 70 liter regen
pro quadratmeter fallen für die meisten
von uns reicht es aber wohl nur für ein
bis 30 liter pro quadratmeter
immerhin ist das ja auch schon mal was
ab mittwoch kommen dann die kräftigen
schauer und gewitter von westen heran
und am freitag ist es dann deutlich
kühler liegen die höchsttemperatur nur
noch bei 18 bis 26 grad und diese
gewitter die sind mit hagel platzregen
und sturmböen verbunden wie sie hier am
trend für regensburg sehen können
allerdings wird es schon nächste woche
wieder sommerlich warm mit werten um die
25 grad nachts liegen die werte um 15
grad guten abend